the b-2 stealth bomber is probably one
of the most iconic planes to have ever
been built it's sleek flying wing design
makes it practically invisible to radar
an incredibly fuel-efficient allowing it
to penetrate even the most sophisticated
of enemy defenses but how did this
incredible aircraft come into existence
and what technological advancements made
it possible
the rise of stealth aircraft can be
tracked back to World War one
when the Germans attempted to use
transparent canvas to make their planes
difficult to spot dot plan backfired as
the glossy canvas made the aircraft even
more visible in sunlight the demand for
stealth aircraft as we think of them
today rose with the advancement of
practical radar technology in the 1930s
the technology formed the backbone of
Britain's early warning system during
the Battle of Britain saving uncountable
eyes from German bombing runs let's see
other technology works radar works by
sending short pulses of electromagnetic
energy in the form of radio waves hours
the attend then switches the receiver
mode and waits to detect the reflections
of these radio waves off distant objects
the radar now receives a blip on the
screen called a radar cross-section
and its size changes with the magnitude
of radio waves returning to the attempt
the radar cross-section is a measure of
how detectable an object is with radar
the size of the object is just one
factor which can be mitigated with
clever engineering the b2 has a
fifty-two meter wingspan yet it has been
reported to have the same radar
cross-section as a large bird so how
does the b2 manage to achieve this
incredible feat the core concept behind
the b2 is reflection it was designed to
reflect the radio waves away from the
source so that they never get the chance
to be detected what is amazing is that
every surface of the b2 has been
designed with this in mind the aircraft
was designed with the aid of
computational models and a supercomputer
which resulted in an incredibly complex
curved shape this technology was not
available during the development of the
f-117 nighthawk resulting in its much
simpler faceted to flat panels the b2 s
radar cross-section is further reduced
by its streamlined flying wing design
but it's highly reflective engines
embedded
in the aircraft where Raider I cannot
see it even the engines air intakes and
exhaust vents are located on top of the
plane to ensure they cannot be detected
by ground-based devices but the flying
wing has some unique flying
characteristics that took many years for
Northrop to perfect one of the most
notable is the lack of a tail rotor to
control y'all the b2 instead uses split
rudders on the tips of the left and
right wing they act as air brakes to
slow either side of the wing and cause
the yaw motion but when in use the split
rotors can increase the radar
cross-section of the plane so the v2 can
also use differential crossing of its
left and right engines to allowed to be
controlled when stealth is a priority
beyond its shape the b2 is also made
with advanced constant materials which
are capable of absorbing and dissipating
incoming radio energy the exact
composition of the b2 is classified but
we know that the skin is made from a
carbon fiber reinforced plastic while
the leading edge of the b2 is likely
painted with a material which contains
small particles of iron which absorb
electromagnetic energy and converts it
to heat with these technologies combined
the b2 barely even registers on radar
screens what is even more terrifying to
think about is the fact that the Nazis
had created a very similar plane all the
way back in 1944 the Horten 2 to 9
incorporated many of the same principles
as the be too long before the stealth
technology that made the b2 possible was
fully understood today we can only
imagine the impact this plane would have
had if it was ready before the war's end
thanks for watching and welcome to all
my new subscribers I told myself I would
not set up a patreon account until I hit
10,000 subscribers and I blew through
that goal with my previous video so the
link for that is below along with my
Instagram Facebook and Twitter accounts
I'm really excited for my next video so
make sure to subscribe and watch it when
it comes out